[Musik]
tatütata die feuerwehr ist da hallo
hallo karin also früher ist die
feuerwehr ja bei uns nur unfreiwillig
durch gefahren weil ich an einer sehr
lauten straße wohnte und jetzt hast du
sie durchfahren lassen wie kommt das
denn richtig heute war es ein spezial
soundeffekt denn herzlich willkommen zur
episode 1 12 von unserem podcast 112 ja
was bedeutet das denn manuel 112 das ist
nicht nur unsere episoden nummer sondern
das ist auch unser thema der woche
mensch manuel das ist aber gewiss dass
wir das jetzt miteinander verbinden
die soden thema und das thema der woche
112 ist eine telefonnummer
richtig eine sehr kurze telefonnummer
und in amerika ist es die nano an und in
europa nicht nur in deutschland ist es
das ist der notruf damit erreicht man
die feuerwehr und den krankenwagen und
zwar in ganz europa wie ich ja vor
kurzem erst gelernt habe ich bin
allerdings nicht alleine 71 prozent der
menschen wissen nicht dass man in der
ganzen eu mit 112 die feuerwehr anrufen
kann
das ist verrückt dann leisten wir jetzt
hier mit sozusagen einen beitrag dass
das mehr menschen hoffentlich lernen wie
ist das denn bei der kali hast du schon
mal die 112 gewählt
selten tatsächlich ich habe aber einmal
habe ich tatsächlich 112 angerufen
als ich einen notfall waren nahmen die
112 kann man ja immer anrufen bei
verschiedenen notfällen wenn ihr zum
beispiel ein haus brennt kann man die
anrufen aber auch wenn jemand vielleicht
umgekippt ist und man einen
rettungswagen bauch und wir hatten
tatsächlich eine krasse geschichte
erlebt ich war mit janisch in der u bahn
in berlin ich glaube ich habe die
geschichte sogar schon mal
dann erzählt hier im podcast erinnerst
du dich ja auf jeden fall saßen in der
u-bahn und da ist plötzlich jemand der
lag offen sitz der so aus als würde er
schlafen und dann ist er einfach so vom
sitz gerollt und mit dem kopf richtig
auf auf dem auf dem boden aufgeschlagen
und hat sich danach nicht bewegt und das
hat natürlich leuten angst gemacht ist
dann immer so hin und her gerollt auf
dem fußboden
dann ist mal jemand da hingegangen hat
versucht ihn anzusprechen ohne erfolg
und dann sah da saßen irgendwie weiß
nicht zehn leute in diesem waggon und
keiner wusste was er machen sollte und
dann dachte ich ja okay dann bevor wir
jetzt nichts machen habe ich dann den
notruf angerufen 112 und da war ich dann
obwohl wir in einem tunnel waren
verbunden mit einem rettungsdienst und
der hat mir dann instruktionen gegeben
der hat gesagt gehen sie da mal hin und
kneifen sie diesen mann in den oberarm
greifen ist auf englisch so kritisch
genau das wusste ich nicht kneifen also
eine ja sehr stark vielleicht weh tun
und das habe ich dann gemacht ich habe
diesen mann gekniffen nachdem wir ja
schon versucht haben mit ihnen zu
sprechen er ist nicht aufgewacht dann
habe ich war ja noch am telefon habe der
mann gesagt ja es ist nichts passiert da
meinte er machen sie das nochmal so doll
wie sie können wieder nichts passiert
und dann hat er so ganz nüchtern ganz
neutral gesagt ja dann bleibt ihnen
jetzt nur noch eins frau schmidt sie
müssen jetzt die notbremse betätigen und
ich sind um gott ich die note wert von
dem zug und dann habe ich die notbremse
gezogen und dann kam erstmals ohne dann
ist der der ich weiß gar nicht mehr ob
der zug sofort gestoppt ist auf jeden
fall kam dann eine durchsage von dem
schaffner und der sagte nur wer hat hier
die notbremse gezogen weil das
wahrscheinlich viele auch als scherz
machen dann habe ich gesagt ja ich bin
in wagen ganz hinten
und hier ist jemand ohnmächtig oder
bewusstlos und ich habe schon den
rettungsdienst angerufen er hat mir
gesagt die notbremse zu ziehen und dann
hat er durch gesagt durch den ganzen
wagen ja wir werden jetzt in den
nächsten bahnhof einfahren damit der
rettungsdienst kommen kann und wenn es
ärzte im zug gibt sollen die bitte in
den waggon kommen und dann kam leichter
je fünf ärzte kamen direkt in den waggon
und die haben dann eben geguckt ob es
dem ja ob der noch atmet und so und
tatsächlich hat der mann noch geatmet
aber war nicht ansprechbar
also man weiß nicht was mit ihm passiert
ist ob das jetzt medizinischer notfall
war oder vielleicht drogen alkohol im
spiel waren dass sowas passiert
natürlich in berlin
ja und dann das krasse was dann
eigentlich passiert ist ist das ein
rettungsdienst kam den abgeholt hat und
die waren sauer dass überhaupt jemand
den rettungsdienst gerufen hat weil aus
ihrer sicht war das kein medizinischer
notfall sondern ein betrunkener der ja
dann haben die tatsächlich so gefragt
wer hat hier den rettungsdienst gerufen
und waren ziemlich schlecht drauf
das finde ich ein bisschen schade zu
hören weil ich oft gesagt bekommen habe
und auch in den erste hilfe kursen die
ich zum beispiel gemacht hab ich habe
mehrere schon machen können da wird
immer gesagt ist es immer besser im
zweifel etwas zu machen als nichts zu
machen selbst wenn man nicht genau weiß
was ist jetzt das richtige mindestens
anrufen und irgendwas machen die person
ansprechen ist immer besser als zu sagen
dass es mir jetzt zu gefährlich ich
mache jetzt lieber gar nichts insofern
ja und das ist ja auch strafbar es gibt
ja diesen im deutschen diesen begriff
unterlassene hilfeleistung also eine
hilfe die unterlassen wird also die
nicht gemacht wird und wenn man zum
beispiel sich bei einem unfall oder
irgendwo entfernt wo jemand gerade in
einem notfall ist dann ich weiß nicht
genau was das für rechtliche
konsequenzen hat aber es ist auf jeden
fall sowohl rechtlich als auch moralisch
moralisch allein schon schwierig zu
sagen ich
ich gehe jetzt einfach weg und das ist
mir auch so direkt in den kopf gekommen
es gab mal einen bekannten fall wo in
einer sparkasse ein mann kollabiert ist
mit einem weiß ich gar nicht ein
herzinfarkt oder so und der mann
tatsächlich in einer bank gestorben ist
am tag und kein mensch da war oder kein
mensch ihn angesprochen hat weil alle
dachten das wäre vielleicht ein
betrunkener der einfach auf dem fußboden
schläft und sowas ist natürlich tragisch
deshalb würde ich auch jeden ermutigen
und das haben dann später auch leute
gemacht nachdem die weg waren mit ihrer
schlechten laune und den typen kam dann
tatsächlich mehrere leute im zug zu mir
und haben gesagt sie ja danke dass du
das gemacht hast du hast das richtige
gemacht und ich würde das auch wieder
tun das denke ich auch gut
manuel hast du denn schon mal den
rettungsdienst rufen müssen
ja ich habe sogar mal also auch die 112
gerufen um die feuerwehr zu erreichen
ja und zwar war das vor ein paar jahren
da ist meine mutter in ein neues haus
gezogen und wir mussten dieses haus erst
mal renovieren ich hab da bei der
renovierung geholfen und wir haben da
den ganzen tag gearbeitet und gestreikt
und das war natürlich noch strichen
gestrichen gesteht ich hatte mir
überlegt dass gestreckte gestrichen also
liebe deutschlehrer das ist auch als
deutschland manchmal nicht so ganz
leicht
also wir haben den ganzen tag die wände
gestrichen wir haben da alles mögliche
gemacht und dann war es schon ziemlich
spät abends es war schon dunkel und und
wir hatten so zischgeräusche immer im
keller so ganz komisches geräusch und
dann sind wir runter gegangen und es
roch nach gas ist doch einfach nach gas
und wir dachten oh scheiße also das ist
natürlich nicht gut diese geräusche und
dieser gasgeruch aber es war auch so
eine situation wo wir uns hat sich nicht
sicher sind war das jetzt wirklich was
und ich hab dann die einzelnen zwei
gerufen und habe diese situation
geschildert und habe gesagt so könnten
sie vielleicht mal
eine person verschicken die sich das mal
anguckt und er meint das haben die mit
sicherheit eine version niemals und
gucken kommt richtig er meinte dann so
ganz trocken so also wenn wir kommen
dann kommen wir richtig und das machen
wir dann jetzt
und dann kamen wirklich zwei oder drei
so richtig riesige feuerwehrautos ja
also ich weiß nicht wie die wie die
heißen das sind ja wirklich so
mannschaftswagen hingeben wagen
irgendwie sechs leute drin
die kamen dann da erfolge fahren das ist
auch auf dem land und natürlich die
ganze nachbarschaft irgendwie am fenster
und dann kam die raus und sind in das
haus rein auch ganz vorsichtig mit zu
spezial taschenlampen haben keine
lichter an gemacht haben erst mal alle
fenster aufgerissen und so und haben
dann auch gerochen und mindestens einer
von denen meinte dann auch soja also für
mich bricht auch nach gas und die haben
dann einen spezial menschen aus dem bett
geklingelt der kam dann irgendwie aus
der nächstgelegenen stadt mit einem
speziellen messgerät das dauerte das mal
20 minuten bis der kam und der lief dann
mit dem messgerät durch das haus hat
alles gemessen und hat dann die
entwarnung gegeben also es war dann kein
gas es stellte sich dann später heraus
dass die die geräusche kamen von so
einer anlage im keller die wir noch
nicht kannten die das wasser einfach
gefiltert hat und der geruch das habe
ich dann auch gelernt der kam von der
trockenen farbe wenn farbe trocknet dann
riecht es ein bisschen faul manchmal und
das ist so ein ähnlicher geruch wie gas
und die feuerwehrleute die meinten dann
nämlich auch so keine ursache wir sind
gerne gekommen und wenn noch mal was ist
einfach wieder anrufen also die waren
ganz entspannt wie nett die also diese
tanja wirklich aber wenn die das nicht
mal selber wussten also wenn die
spezialisten rufen mussten
dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
einfach gewesen das festzustellen
vorsicht ist besser als nachsicht sagt
man ja im deutschen was noch ganz
interessant war bei der sache war dass
das die freiwillige feuerwehr war die da
kam in deutschland gibt es ja eine
berufsfeuerwehr und eine freiwillige
feuerwehr und die freiwillige feuerwehr
das sind alles ehrenamtliche die machen
das einfach ja die werden glaube ich gar
nicht für bezahlt oder richtig dass in
ehrenamtliche und trotzdem aber profis
also die ausgebildet werden und manchmal
haben die auch tatsächlich hauptamtliche
leute also menschen die das
hauptberuflich machen
ich habe mich da mal ein bisschen
eingelesen vor unserer episode und habe
auch einen link als tipp wo man ein
bisschen was über die geschichte der
freiwilligen feuerwehr lesen kann und
ich wusste gar nicht dass in deutschland
70 prozent der feuerwehr freiwillige
feuerwehr ist und das ist ziemlich
interessant diese ganze geschichte
die freiwillige feuerwehr gibt es noch
gar nicht
also gibt es schon so glaube ich 200
jahre aber davor waren die leute selber
dafür zuständig ihr haus zu löschen was
natürlich ein bisschen doof ist weil
wenn je nachdem wie viele leute da jetzt
bei dir sind oder im haus wohnen oder
gerade verfügbar sind ist das natürlich
eine schwierige angelegenheit
und da ist die freiwillige feuerwehr die
sich gegenseitig hilft natürlich gut
also habe ich einen link in den schoß
falls euch das interessiert die
geschichte der freiwilligen feuerwehr in
deutschland gibt es auch in anderen
ländern und kommt wohl ursprünglich aus
frankreich das konzept interessant ja
also was ist unser fazit für heute im
zweifel anrufen oder im zweifelsfall die
feuerwehr rufen genau und und das ist ja
auch so da ist ja jemand am telefon dann
der dich berät also du musst keine angst
haben dass dann das du jemand nervst
auch wenn das vielleicht in meinem fall
so war dass die dann genervt reagiert
haben aber da ist ja jemand am telefon
der genau fragt wo bist du was ist
passiert der auch darauf trainiert ist
in notfällen mit menschen zu
kommunizieren und der wird dann ja mit
dir die entscheidung treffen was zu tun
ist ob dann jemand wirklich kommt oder
nicht
insofern im zweifelsfall anrufen
[Musik]
empfehlungen der woche
manuel carré ich mag unsere empfehlungen
ich freue mich immer über empfehlungen
auch in anderen podcasts und ich dachte
ich frage dich heute mal was hast du
eigentlich zuletzt gewünscht gewinnst du
meinst damit keine drogen und kein
alkohol vermute ich denn du weißt ich
trinke sehr wenig kann man dieses wort
auch für alkohol und drogen benutzen
daher kommt das ja eigentlich eigentlich
gibt es ja dieses wind trinke ich kenne
das aus amerika warum also was weiß ich
gar nicht mehr
das weiß ich gar nicht es gibt halt aber
tatsächlich ist das im deutschen nur
übernommen worden im sinne von binche
watching und natürlich wird dieser
begriff wie auch alle anderen werben die
aus dem englischen übernommen werden
angedeutet also mit den deutschen
änderungen versehen gewünscht hast du
wieder was gewünscht die tage ich bin
tatsächlich gerade etwas und zwar wie
office die amerikanische version von the
office ich hatte das nie gesehen in
meinem in meinem ganzen leben aber meine
freundin ist ein großer fan und wir
schauen gerade von vorne bis hinten alle
14 staffeln durch und es ist es wirklich
verdammt lustig ist es sehr sehr schön
und einem eine empfehlung wäre aber
neben dem amerikanischen die office und
das britische soll auch sehr gut sein
dass deutsche wie office das wissen
nämlich viele nicht das ist das auch
gerd oder gar und das heißt stromberg
ist ein ganz anderer humor ist auch vom
gefühl her ganz anders aber es ist eben
das gleiche konzept also es ist auch ein
büro ein versicherungsbüro und so ein
verstecktes kamerateam was die ganze
zeit
die leute verfolgt und so ein chef der
halt unmöglich ist und immer total die
fürchterlichen sexistischen und
rassistischen sprüche macht und witze
macht aber eigentlich niemandem etwas
böses will mit dem man eigentlich die
ganze zeit so mitleid hat und das ist
glaube ich wenn man deutschen humor so
verstehen will eine gute empfehlung
stromberg stimmt nicht nur deutschen
humor sondern auch dieses deutsche
bürokratie wird dort perfekt abgebildet
also leute die immer tausend mal erst
mal überlegen müssen nachfragen müssen
die ganz genaue abläufe mögen es wird
nichts spontan gemacht und aber auch so
ein bisschen diese deutsche kultur dass
man dann im büro auch mal ein glas sekt
trinkt zum mittagessen und dann so sich
zwingen musste humor zu haben
mit karneval und solchen geschichten
also wirklich sehr gut obwohl es schon
alt ist bis wann sind denn die
amerikanischen office staffeln gegangen
die gibt es doch wahrscheinlich nicht
auch schon ja ich bin gerade was ganz
aktuelles manuell und möchte dir das
gerne empfehlen und allen anderen die
auf sowas bock haben
ich gucke jetzt die gerade die vierte
staffel von frauen die gerade am sonntag
aus gekommen ist und habe direkt am
ersten tag drei folgen durch gewünscht
erzählt worum geht es da es geht um die
historische cook thronfolge oder so oder
nie habe ich noch nie geguckt genau es
geht um die eigentlich um die
königsfamilie in england über die
verschiedenen jahrzehnte für jedes
jahrzehnt gibt es eine staffel und das
ist jetzt das vierte jahrzehnt das fängt
1979 an und spielt in den 80ern
es gibt 60 50er 60er 70er 80er vierte
staffel
das heißt es kommen noch 23 404 und ich
muss sagen ich habe es auch schon
versucht ihr sie nahe zu legen
sie liebe grüße du hast ja gerade hinter
den kulissen zu und es geht im prinzip
darum ist es toll weil es ist extrem
aufwendig gemacht also es ist wirklich
wie ein spielfilm produziert mit richtig
guter kamera guten szenen guten
darstellern
und es spielt historische ereignisse
nach wo man eigentlich denkt okay was
ist denn passiert ist ja gar nicht so
viel passiert aber es ist ja unglaublich
viel passiert in den also muss dir
vorstellen die fünfziger jahre die 60er
jahre in jeweils zehn stunden aus
britischer sicht und quasi die royal
family oder die königsfamilie sind halt
das center punkt oder das ja der fokus
des geschehens aber es geht daneben um
alles um alles was halt sowieso in
dieser zeit passiert und von
kolonialismus über der erste die erste
das erste aufkommen von smog in den 50er
60er jahren wo ganz viele unfälle
passiert sind also was wusste ich gar
nicht jetzt geht es gerade um die iaa
und die unabhängigkeitsbewegung in
irland
und ich muss sagen ich guck das und habe
gleichzeitig immer wikipedia auf und
lässt die ganze geschichte
großbritanniens noch mal nach und ist es
einfach gut gemacht und spannend bist du
jetzt auch begeistert manuel ich höre
dich nicht
technische fehler lasse mich wieder ich
werde ich ja sehr gut
margarida hast du mir lust gemacht dass
auch mal anzuschauen
es kommt auf meine lange liste an serien
die ich gerne gucken möchte richte mir
mal so bevor wir gleich wieder eure
fragen entgegen nehmen also diejenigen
die jetzt live im live stream schauen
ihr könnt uns alles fragen schreibt eure
fragen einfach in den chat aber davor
haben wir einen kleinen hinweis und eine
kleine bitte denn wir könnten das hier
alles gar nicht machen wenn wir nicht so
viele tolle zuhörerinnen und zuhörer
hätten die uns als mitglied unterstützen
und wir dachten wir zeigen euch heute
mal ja jetzt wo wir hier schon die
kamera haben und auch etwas zeigen
können was ihr als mitglied im gegenzug
auch bekommt wenn ihr ein mitglied von
easy german werden und zwar bekommt ihr
für den podcast dann zu jeder episode 1
interaktives transkript das sieht so aus
also da könnt ihr dann im podcast hören
und während ihr hört scrollt er durch
und zeigt jedes einzelne wort markiert
also das ist wirklich sehr gut
um dem text folgen zu können und es ist
hier sogar so eine übersetzungsfunktion
mit dabei das heißt ihr könnt
tatsächlich jeden absatz auch übersetzen
jetzt habe ich hier gerade spanisch
eingestellt die sprache könnt ihr euch
auch aussuchen und was ihr noch hier
daneben sieht dieses diese vokabeln
das ist die vokabel hilfe das heißt ihr
könnt auch auf dem handy beim zuhören da
seht ihr dann immer eine liste mit den
wichtigsten vokabeln aus der aktuellen
minute und die übersetzung auf englisch
und das ändert sich dann jede minute
und das ist eine gute hilfe beim lernen
kann ich ja auch noch was ich möchte
mich noch mal bedanken bei unseren fans
natürlich bei all unseren mitgliedern
aber ganz besonders bei unseren neuen
patch 1 in unserer nation membership
tier und zwar haben wir dazu aufgerufen
dass wir uns auch equipment sponsoren
könnt und das war zum beispiel mit
gemacht und ich habe mir ganz stolz das
ist mein größter größter spaß diese
woche gewesen ich habe mir eine
etikettiermaschine bestellt hast du das
schon mal gesehen sieht aus wie ein ufo
und hier ist das geräusch als mikrofon
kommt klingt gar nicht so toll hier
stand sich gerade einen buchstaben ein
in eine in 100 man das in einer ethik in
ein label aber ein etikett auf englisch
heißt das label maker und unter anderem
haben wir jetzt ein mikrofon von rick
aus den usa gesponsert und wir bekleben
die dann auch und das ist mein großer
spaß
danke an alle von euch vielen dank
und wenn ihr schon mitglied seit dann
denkt bitte daran dass ihr diesen monat
eure mitgliedschaft einmal aktualisieren
müsst geht da bitte einfach auf unsere
website und da steht
wie das geht damit würden wir uns eine
große freude machen hoch da kommt schon
das nächste eure fragen manuell yakari
du hast ja gerade die spanischen
untertiteln gezeigt und wir haben da
direkt eine frage für dich wir
überfallen dich jetzt marlies los aber
ich weiß dass du so fließend spanisch
bist dass du das ganz spontan
beantworten kannst und zwar möchte
ornella unbedingt hören können wir hören
wie manuel auf spanisch spricht
roller ort naja kommt es dass jetzt
mangels masse - ab wenn die in mexiko
salons und das hab ich sogar verstanden
die ja das war jetzt basis level aber
ich lerne schon seit sehr langer zeit
spanisch also mittlerweile ist das auf
einem ok niveau ja ich kann auch
spanisch sprechen
ola yo soy kari weißt du was witzig ist
janus lernt jetzt auch spanisch und
immer wenn er mir jetzt nachrichten
schreibt private nachrichten einfach an
mich dann schreibt er die auf polnisch
übersetzt die mittel auf spanisch und
schickt mir die in spanisch zur übung es
ist sehr lustig das passt ja super zur
frage von martin martin fragt wo ist
janisch und worüber philosophiert er
heute ja es ist tatsächlich in seinem
zimmer hier bei mir nebenan und er guckt
uns geradezu also liebe grüße an janisch
und wir werden ihn bald wieder in
unserem podcast zu gast haben er
philosophiert viel jeden tag also das
kann man schon sagen und sein neues
lieblingsthema ist an dem er diese woche
arbeitet bücher und zwar haben wir
menschen auf der straße gefragt diese
woche was ist eure buchempfehlung und
zwar auch speziell für menschen die
deutsch lernen und das seht ihr am
sonntag bei easy därmen wir haben neues
thema und janisch hat sich schon selber
eine liste gemacht mit büchertipps die
er für deutschlerner hat und er meinte
ich soeben zu ihm ja wo willst du denn
diese liste posten damit soja die will
er sonntagabend alle in die kommentare
unter das easy german wie die schrift
sehr gut das passt zur frau
von chattern lesen sie auch ein buch
gerade oder haben sie eine empfehlung
das problem ist ich lese fast nur bücher
auf englisch deswegen sind das keine
guten empfehlungen für für deutschlerner
aber ich lese unter anderem gerade ein
fantastisches und sehr bekanntes buch
das heißt history of the united states
und da geht es um die geschichte der
vereinigten staaten finde ich gerade in
diesem moment sehr interessant für
deutschland dann hoffentlich im easy
german video mehr empfehlungen
das sei ein guter tipp dann hat alex i
geschrieben liebe grüße aus finnland
liebe grüße nach finnland
da war ich noch nie was du schon mal in
finnland leider nicht aber es ist ganz
weit oben auf meiner liste muss
wunderschön sein und ich mag es
skandinavien generell sehr gerne
wo warst du schon in skandinavien in
schweden in dänemark ich glaube das
war's dann fehlt noch finnland und
norwegen
ja er schreibt wie kann man euch in
berlin treffen schickt man euch eine
nachricht oder sondern außerhalb ihres
büros kari schreien selten da also
begrenzt es mal probieren aber das ist
auf jeden fall eine gute taktik sich
force büro stellen und kari schreien
ich bin wirklich sehr selten im büro
jetzt seit der korona zeit eigentlich
fast gar nicht mehr muss ich sagen
und ansonsten ja ist das einfach wegen
krone im moment so dass man uns nicht so
oft trifft man kann uns manchmal auf der
straße treffen ansonsten organisieren
wir gar nichts ist ist ja auch ein lock
down in deutschland und ich freue mich
schon sehr wieder aufs nächste jahr denn
wir haben eigentlich regelmäßige treffen
mit unseren zuschauern in einer kneipe
in berlin und das war immer sehr nett
manuel das ist ja stimmt größer geworden
und ich muss sagen ich freue mich
unheimlich wieder das ist eine der
sachen die ich am meisten vermisse jetzt
während dieser corona zeit das haben wir
jetzt seit acht monaten nicht mehr
gemacht
nächstes jahr gibt es ganz große treffen
richtig eventuell wir versprechen jetzt
noch nichts aber eventuell apropos
mitgliedschaft wollen wir versuchen mit
einigen unseren mitgliedern demnächst
mal ein virtuelles meetup zu machen
es gibt ja diesen community membership
bei uns auf bachelor aber das können wir
noch nicht versprechen aber wir würden
wirklich gerne mit ups wieder machen
durfte habe ich ein stück von meinem
label maker etikett auf dem pullover
ganz und gar santa war
was ist unser highlight der woche mein
highlight der woche
[Gelächter]
okay das kann man jetzt nicht sehen wenn
man diesen podcast nicht bei youtube
sieht aber ihr könnt es hören kannst du
das geräusch noch mal machen manuel ich
habe einen neuen schreibtisch und immer
ein steh schreibtisch den mann zwischen
stehen und sitzen immer hin und her
elektrisch stellen kann und das habe ich
mir gegönnt und das ist ganz fantastisch
das arbeiten hat eine neue qualität
erreicht bei mir ja und manuel macht
immer witze damit in unseren meetings
dass er einfach plötzlich den
schreibtisch hochfährt und dann sieht
man seinen kopf wie sein kopf immer
kleiner wird und der schreibtisch an
also quasi auch der laptop wegfährt von
manuel kann man sich viele scherze mit
erlauben man hier ist eine ganz
dringende frage von dennis was ist deine
meinung zu star trek
daher mache ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich
keine freunde mit aber ich bin weder ein
star wars noch ein star trek fan ich bin
also eigentlich gar kein nerd das war
nur ein gerücht
ich konnte mich nie mit diesen science
fiction sachen so anfreunden ich weiß
nicht magst du das ich habe tatsächlich
ich gucke auch beides nicht und das ist
immer peinlich zuzugeben dass ich fast
ich glaube ich habe einen star wars film
gesehen und ich weiß nicht mal welche so
geht es mir auch aber zum beispiel ich
weiß dass ich das das ist so etwas wo
ich weiß was ich das irgendwann gerne
mal durch drucke und dann auch bock
drauf habe also dann werde ich mal
alle star wars filme nacheinander gucken
ich habe tatsächlich frühjahr star trek
geguckt als ich weiß gar nicht wie alt
ich da war vielleicht entweder war ich
zwölf oder 17
interessant aber nicht schützen ich weiß
es nicht aber ich habe tatsächlich am
anfang star trek geguckt da kommt direkt
noch eine fernseh frage die die ich auch
sehr gerne beantworte katie schreibt
habt ihr die neue zdf satirische serie
gesehen zdf-magazin royalen es ist
genauso gut wie die heute schon hast du
dir schon gesehen meine ja das ist doch
mit jan böhmermann jaja belastend
gesehen
ach so jetzt irgendwie diese woche nee
ich hab das vor einem jahr oder so mal
gesehen richtig ist wir vorher bei
zdfneo und hieß das neo magazin royal
dann haben sie fast ein jahr pause
gemacht und jetzt bei zdf nach der heute
show sehr lange hat er darum gekämpft in
die zur primetime auf dem hauptsender
einen sendeplatz zu bekommen
und ich muss sagen dass die erste folge
eher enttäuschend war die zweite dafür
umso besser also ich kann empfehlen die
letzte folge vom letzten freitag zu
sehen
und ich gucke mir tatsächlich auch
beides immer freitags abends an die
heute show und das zdf-magazin royal
deutschland ich muss sagen es nicht so
gut in so in sendungen wie einige
sendung in den usa sind und oft ist das
ja so dass die formate auch so ein
bisschen kopiert sind also jan
böhmermann versucht so was ähnliches zu
machen wie jean oliver zb und ganz oft
gelingt das auch aber auch ganz oft so
mittelmäßig
ja aber ich bin schon ein zuschauer von
diesem format takko besagt schon wieder
eine episode für rentner
das harsche kritik was haben wir noch
hier fragt jemand ob schlagermusik
apropos rentner ob schlager musik in
deutschland beliebt und bekannt ist hast
du manchmal schlagermusik
also bekannt und beliebt ist sie
tatsächlich und das ist etwas was viele
deutsche furchtbar finden wie zum
beispiel ich und auch ein bisschen
peinlich ich finde deutsche musik es
gibt schon gut in deutschland musik aber
insgesamt muss ich sagen haben wir auch
schon mal im podcast drüber gesprochen
wenn man in england ist dann hört man in
allen papst eigentlich gute musik aus
den letzten 50 60 jahren bis heute und
in deutschland ist es wirklich man hat
entweder techno schlager oder irgendwie
sowas wie rammstein und ich kann mich
mit keinem dieser musikstile sonderlich
anfreunden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so fragt warum ist unser podcast nicht
mehr so lange wie früher
das liegt daran dass wir statt einmal in
der woche drei mal in der woche senden
jedes mal ungefähr eine halbe stunde
also insgesamt machen wir mehr podcast
als früher
und man kann uns öfter hören
so sieht's aus manuel da kam gerade noch
eine frage von john f und er fragt wie
funktionieren denn die rettungsdienste
in deutschland sind die zentral
koordiniert oder ruft man einen
spezifischen dienst an zum beispiel das
rote kreuz
ich weiß es nicht aber ich glaube das
ist in jeder stadt oder in jeder region
gibt es sozusagen ein zentrum was
zentral koordiniert und die koordinieren
dann die rettungswagen die von
unterschiedlichen organisationen
betrieben werden genau
also ja kann man schon sagen dass das
zentral koordiniert ist man muss sich
jetzt nicht überlegen rufe ich jetzt
beim roten kreuz an oder bei der
berufsfeuerwehr oder der freiwilligen
feuerwehr weil die einen vielleicht gar
nicht antworten
man hat eine notfallnummer die ruft man
an und dann wird man mit dem verbunden
der ich glaube die rettungsstelle ist
zentral und die leiten das dann weiter
an denen der verfügbar ist vielleicht
machen wir da ja noch mal eine ganze
sendung darüber denn ich kenne auch
jemanden der zum beispiel
rettungssanitäter ist und ich finde das
wirklich ein spannendes thema
super spannendes thema würde ich auch
gerne mal mehr erfahren
yakari ich denke immer noch über tacos
kommentaren mit gerechnet dass das hier
gefeatured wird ihr könnt uns natürlich
auch jederzeit fragen stellen wenn wir
nicht gerade live senden auf easy german
punkt fm da ist unten so ein knopf eure
fragen könnte uns auch eine
sprachnachricht schicken
dann spielen wir vielleicht ab im
podcast und genau das sollten wir mal
wieder machen ne das ist meine sprache
nach spielen zum schluss möchte ich mich
noch mal gedanken an unser team hinter
den kulissen das ist nämlich unter
anderem easy die auch live dabei ist
aber nicht hier
vor der kamera ist ich hoffe das wird
aber vielleicht nächstes mal oder
übernächstes mal der fall sein wenn sie
ihr neues podcast equipment bekommt und
dann ist da noch francisco der hinter
den kulissen hier alles managt francisco
du kannst mal alle alle bilder
vertauschen wenn man jetzt gerade auf
youtube zu guckt dann sieht man was
francisco alles magisches machen kann er
kann das bild groß und klein machen er
kann uns verwechseln
er kann sachen einblenden er ist also
unser produktionsmanager und francisco
könnt ihr ansonsten auch bei easy
spanish auch nicht vor der kamera sehen
weiß ich gar nicht was ich auch sagen
arbeitsschritt bewundern
er macht was genau den kulissen das ist
geschneidert quasi fast alle easy
spanish episoden schön kari dann hören
wir uns am samstag schon wieder in
unserem normalen podcast verrückt
verrückt an sitzungen zum ende noch mal
die noch mal was schönes spielen
es ist eigentlich gar nicht so gut ist
apple das ist nicht so ein schönes ende
aber verabschieden uns mit tatütata die
feuerwehr ist da ist das eigentlichen
ist das eigentliche ich habe mich
gefragt wo das herkommt ist das ein
kinderlied das weiß ich nicht
den titel hast du dir ja ausgesucht ich
weiß nicht genau wo das ja kommt ja weil
man das als kind immer hört ich glaube
das ist ein kinderbuch und das als kind
also die quasi die art wie man das
verschriftlicht diese sirene im
deutschen ist tatütata ja das ist
eigentlich total verrückt waren okay ich
verabschiede mich ich bin schon ganz
hibbelig ich habe nämlich einen kaffee
getrunken muss jetzt erstmal
runterkommen mit dem glas wasser brust
bis bald kam